welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition and this
is the channel where we explain it so
you don't have to wow
what can i say well avengers endgame is
set to be released next week and whilst
trailers have initially depicted certain
scenes
today there was five minutes of footage
leaked onto youtube
this is clearly legit emma and comes
from screenings and paints out the plot
as well as what will be happening in the
film
and honestly whilst the quality is quite
low it still looks outstanding
throughout this video i'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the footage as well as what it
means for the movie
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to know anything about the
film
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now as there are massive
massive spoilers going to be in this
video that's your last warning
and with that out the way i hope you
enjoy the video
now sit back relax and let's unpack the
five minutes of leaked footage from the
film
the opening scene from the video
showcases professor hulk and the team
bantering back and forth
the meld between banner and his alter
ego has long been theorized and it's
great to see that the character
is definitely going to be in the movie
now he actually plays a massive part in
the film which i'll get into later in
the video
but damn it's good to see him here tony
stark also calls rocket ratchet
to which the character replies take it
easy you're only a genius on earth
the crew then step forward similar to
the footage that we've seen thus far in
trailers
however they're joined by professor hulk
who was clearly cgi out of trailers
we then witnessed them in the battle of
new york from the original avengers
movie
captain america states that they need to
stay low whilst the hulk from that
timeline steps forward and smashes up
some of the chitari
it's a massively comedic scene that
professor hulk seems to be embarrassed
about and it's an amazing call back to
that film
cap also fights himself probably to stop
the past version from interfering
next we see the hulk putting on an
infinity gauntlet as built by tony stark
many leaks said that this would be put
in place so that the characters from the
past could take the infinity stones
themselves in order to wield them and
this confirms it professor hulk will be
the one carrying the stones and he will
be facing thanos which sort of acts as a
redemptive arc for his defeat in
infinity war we then watch thor who's
now gained a giant beard
taking on thanos with the help of iron
man it's an incredible battle that
really showcases that they mean business
finally captain america stands amongst
the destruction and he hears the phrase
on your left
which is when the avengers who were
killed in the snap step out of the
portal
united as one we see all of the
characters from all of the movies on
screen
rushing thanos this is every single
character ranging from
valkyrie spider-man black panther ships
and more
captain america also catches
doors hammer captain america catches
thor's hammer
and it shows that he is worthy this is
sort of a call back to age of ultron and
it's amazing to see him wielding it and
i just can't wait to see him smash that
us
face in with it tony and spider-man
reunite and hug before captain marvel
destroys thanos's ship
we end with carol danvers with short
hair stating that she is their partner
before thanos minions flee his destroyed
ship thus
ending the five minutes now that's all
of the footage and it kind of makes me
wish i wasn't a youtuber who deals in
spoilers
but man this movie looks amazing a lot
of things that have been theorized come
to fruition here and it's amazing seeing
all of the avengers in one shot
back on screen fighting thanos head on
i'm glad that none of the major deaths
were spoiled here and it still leaves a
lot to look forward to
it's incredible that professor hulk is
not only going to be in it but also
wielding an infinity gauntlet and man i
just cannot wait to see them go back in
time and the other locations that they
travel back to
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the movie and what you're looking
forward to the most
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of yesterday's game of thrones
season a
episode 1 which will be linked at the
end
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes
so if that's the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you